so many of us are operating so far under
our potential that it's just like
embarrassing and so this is why it's
like cool on your life look at
your schedule look at what you're doing
look at what you're trying to achieve
and just be like how do I stop doing all
these average mediocre normal things so
I can free up my time and just be world
class at a few things what you're about
to hear is a conversation between me and
jod cook jod is an award-winning
entrepreneur author and actually
professional powerlifter as well she's
built and sold her first business
completely from scratch she's now
working on a software company and she
just does professional powerlifting on
the side alongside traveling the world
as a digital Nomad with her husband
she's also the author of the book of the
10-year career reimagine business design
your life fast track your freedom my dad
had told me this phrase that was
knowledge instills confidence confidence
instills enthusiasm and enthusiasm sells
cars and vans I was selling social media
management but it's no different it's
still the same thing we talk a lot about
what personal success means to different
people and we talk about how you can
build your own personal success system
for yourself and we talk a lot about how
to achieve that version of success for
you in multiple areas of life at the
same time we're being conditioned to
believe that we need to get a job settle
down all those normal lifestyle choices
we don't realize that we're kind of
being led along the path that might not
be right for us something different
might be right for
you this episode is very kindly brought
to you by none other than hu now I've
been a pain customer of hu since 2017 I
first discovered it in my fth of medical
school and if you haven't heard of it
it's basically a meal in a bottle and in
that meal you get a balanced mixture of
carbohydrates and fats and proteins and
fiber and it also contains 26 different
vitamins and minerals and each meal has
around 400 calories and 22 g of protein
so it's pretty reasonable in terms of
protein count and because I tend to be
pretty busy and there's always stuff
going on I tend not to really have time
to get a healthy breakfast or a healthy
lunch and so I'll often use hu ready to
drink as a replacement for my breakfast
or my lunch they've got eight different
flavors that are available my two
favorites are banana and salted caramel
so if you find those you should check
them out and even though hu as a company
started off online direct to Consumer
recently they've propagated amongst all
of like the grocery stores in the UK at
least and so I've been seeing it out and
about everywhere which is pretty cool
I'm very excitingly we also have an
episode with Julian Hearn who is the
founder of hu back on this podcast from
season 1 and so that episode was a real
masterclass entrepreneurship and it was
really cool seeing kind of hearing the
story of exactly how heel came together
so head over to h.com deepdive and thank
you so much H for sponsoring this
episode this episode is sponsored by
kajabi and they've actually got
something really valuable for all of our
Deep dive listeners now if you haven't
heard of kajabi it's basically a
platform that helps creators diversify
their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcasts and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi earlier
this year and as soon as we started
using it we were like oh my God why
haven't we been using this product for
the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online
community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to a $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out over
$6 billion dollar to creators that's
billion with the be and over a thousand
creators have become millionaires
through products on the platform now
back in May 2023 I did a keynote at a
kajabi in real life kajabi Heroes Event
in Austin Texas and in that keynote I
talked about the exact steps that I used
to grow my business from0 to over $2.5
million per year from course Revenue
alone now people paid for the pretty
expensive tickets to watch this keynote
at the kajabi hero live event but as an
exclusive deal for deep dive listeners
kajabi have very kindly offered to
provide the recording of that keynote
completely for free to anyone who
listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well and you
just enter your email address and then
you will get the recording of that
keynote completely for free whether or
not you ever become a kajabi customer so
thank you so much to kajabi for
sponsoring this episode this season is
Once Again being sponsored very kindly
by trading 212 now people ask me all the
time for investment advice uh because
they see that I've made money and I've
made videos talking about where I'm
investing that money the thing that
Warren Buffett and basically everyone
who's sensible in the space recommends
which is to invest in Broad stock market
index funds which you can do completely
for free using trading 212 trading 212
is a fantastic app that lets you invest
in stocks and shares and funds in a
commission-free fashion and they've got
a bunch of features which are really
helpful which is why I personally use
trading 212 to manage a portion of my
portfolio so firstly they've got this
great pies and auto invest feature so if
you're interested in potentially getting
into investing what you can do is you
can browse the different pies that
different people have created on the
platform so you might get like a hedge
font Trader who's gone onto the platform
and has created a p of Investments
having done a bunch of research and
stuff and that P might be like I don't
know 20% Apple 20% Tesla 10% this 10%
that but it generally way more
complicated than that and you can see
the performance of that particular pie
of stocks shares and funds and then if
you want to copy that pie into your own
account you can just copy and paste it
directly in and then you can invest any
amount of money and it will
automatically split it according to the
allocation in the P so if you wanted to
just play around with £1 and you were
like okay that Pi looks good it will
split out that1 based on the allocations
of the pi which is pretty sick they've
also recently added support for
multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of £100 so it's literally free
money so you might as well so thank you
so much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode so Jody um thank you for coming
thank you so much for having me my
understanding is that you started your
first business straight out of
University I did what was the story of
the first business the story of the
first business was that I started it at
the age of 22 with no real business plan
at all other than two words get
clients and how I went about doing that
is I started rocking up to networking
events standing up and saying hey
everyone my name's Jody and I'm a social
media manager and so this was 2011 there
were hardly any social media managers
around because social media wasn't
really a thing it was like a few people
who were famous had Twitter and that was
kind of it so at my company which wasn't
even a company at the time it was just
me pretending to know what I was doing
um we started or I started meeting
people setting them up on social media
after I'd convinced them that they
should be on social media and then
running their accounts for them and I
remember at my first ever Prospect
meeting and I'd never had one before I
didn't really know what to do I just
remember my dad had told me this phrase
that was knowledge instills confidence
confidence instills enthusiasm and
enthusiasm sells cars and vans and so in
his line of work he sold cars and vans
but I was selling social media
management but it's no different it's
still the same thing so I just went with
all these ideas from all this research
I'd done and then probably exploded all
my ideas onto the Prospect and then they
were like okay and then they signed up
and then I had a client and then I
figured that once I had what on I not
only had the confidence that I could
sign up clients but I also had this case
study and so I used that to get client
number two and client number three and
then gradually started building a
business from there and what prompted
you you know you you just graduated from
University you could do anything why did
you decide to start your own business
and then why specifically in social
media before I was 21 I had
had 15 jobs and that was in restaurants
in shops I'd done mystery shopping I'd
done mystery dining I had worked at a
football ground um and I didn't see
finding a job as this thing I really
wanted to do I saw finding a job as a
last resort so when all my friends were
trying to get on different kind of
graduate schemes and and get different
jobs at deoe and PWC and everywhere else
like that that was just that was kind of
the expected role that was the expected
path that everyone went into but I just
thought why are we all trying to get
jobs it's really easy to get a job but
everywhere people will just have you
like why don't we start like why don't
we try and start businesses and so that
was just what I what I tried to do cuz I
figured I have nothing to lose I'm 22 I
think I was living with my parents at
the time I gave myself a deadline of
three months and I thought I'm going to
work this out I'm going to figure out
how I pay my own rent look after myself
and then I'm going to move out and then
I'm just going to run my own business
forever so that sounds very matter of
fact so like I know a lot of people you
know um a lot of our listeners might be
in a similar position where there their
early 20s they've graduated uni they've
got a normal job and you know from the
surveys that we've done a lot of them
are pretty you know it's it's not like
they're homeless on the streets like
they've got parents that they can live
with and yet the pressure is still there
to start climbing the ladder there's
this worry that I don't want to fall
behind in my 20s because your 20s are
for hustling and setting yourself up so
that your 30s can be more chill and like
you see your friends getting the job and
getting the promotion and getting the
the bonuses and stuff at PWC and Dee and
things and it's so easy for people to
think I have to I have to get on the
ladder because if I don't then I'm
falling behind yeah how it's a trap yeah
how do you that I think we are
conditioned to do that I think that the
first conveyor belt that we get on is
the education conveyor belt and that's
where I know you'll have been through
the same one it's like you do your GC
you do your next exams you go to college
University you get on a graduate scheme
and that's just this this path that you
probably don't really question you just
do what's expected of you next and then
after that it's the career con belt and
that's where you just get a job and then
you climb the ladder and everything else
but I think it
doesn't it's not so clear at the start
that you're doing the right thing it's
only clear when you're 10 years on and
you realize that you've got all this
freedom and all this stuff under your
belt that you just believed you could
get to right at the start but it
involves just being happy to be
different being happy to make the
different decisions and look stupid and
look like you might fail but kind of be
okay with that I feel like where I got
to with it was being really hungry to
find just role models other people who'd
done it so um for me I was lucky because
my mom had started a business when I
think I was about 15 so when I was
living at home when I was a teenager I
just had this knowledge of all these
different business terms that I wouldn't
have picked up otherwise so she got
clients and she sent invoices and she
went networking and it's like three
words that you wouldn't know that unless
you had entrepreneurial parents really
so um if I didn't have entrepreneurial
parents it would be like go and get role
models of people who've done it and then
figure out how they do it and like
Shadow them or do work experience with
them or just copy what they do and soak
up it's almost like become an become an
entrepreneur by osmosis because that's
that's how I'd start if I was doing it
now nice to what extent do you think
that
everyone can be an entrepreneur versus
is it like like I guess what what sort
of traits should someone have that
they're thinking of starting their own
business someone recently described
entrepreneurship to me as a game of
constant
reframing and I think I agree with them
because more stuff gets thrown at you in
entrepreneurship than in anything else
so like clients come clients go team
members do you you you're probably
putting out many fires every single day
but all of it is a game of how can I be
okay with this fire that's taking that's
taking place around me and how can I
just get better at putting the fires out
but then dealing with bigger fires after
that so um I think it develops a mental
toughness that not everyone realizes
comes with it and I feel like you have
to be ready for it but once you're ready
for it it's really good when I was
running my agency I started watching Mad
Men
and because that's all about advertising
agencies of the 60s 50s 60s um and
there's one scene in it where one of the
partners at their um what's it called
Sterling Cooper Draper price or just
Sterling Cooper to start with and then
um so there's one scene where one of the
partners is in his office and someone
marches up the hall towards him and says
oh no we've lost cabri like they they've
lost this massive client and it's such a
big deal and he goes are you going to
walk up the hall every time we lose a
client like you'll wear the carpet out
like it's not that much of a big deal
and just putting those things into
perspective and being able to constantly
reframe is like what entrepreneurship is
all about and then you find that less
bothers you and a a quote I actually
heard recently from it was
um Justine musk Elon musk's
exwife and she said to be a successful
entrepreneur you need to get you need to
get comfortable with dealing with a
level of stress that would break most
people and once you get good at it it
doesn't really feel like stress it just
feels like what you do but then you're
so far ahead of what other people can
deal with that you just kind of keep
going from there okay so it sounds like
you feel like sort of if someone if
someone wants to get into the game of
Entrepreneurship they should have a
pretty thick skin to be able to deal
with the stress and the pressure of
it or do you think it's something that
you can just develop over time like yeah
I think you can develop over time but I
think it's not going to be easy and I
think expecting it to be easy makes it
harder I'd rather that someone went in
expecting for it to be really really
really difficult but then they were like
whoa how much growth I'm accessing from
this and then really enjoyed it um and
then carry it on going I don't think
that you need to have it to start with I
think you just need to expect that
you're going to have to work yeah I
think that's a really good point um you
know I think that's sort of I speak to a
lot of people who start off YouTube
channels and then you know they started
off thinking it's not really going to go
anywhere but then it goes somewhere and
they're like oh my goodness like this
thing has gone somewhere and then when
when they started treat it as a business
it starts to be hard and they start to
think oh my God I must be bad I must be
an idiot because I'm finding this hard
and I always trying to be like no no
it's like this is business it's it's
supposed to be hard yeah something you
said there just reminded me that I
actually think a lot of people think
they're scared of failure but I think a
lot of people are actually scared of
success what do you mean because I think
they're scared that they reach a level
of success like you said building a
YouTube channel and it's suddenly taking
off and I think they'll believe that
they won't be able to handle it and
they'll have to cope with new things
that they don't know they can cope with
and they have to they have to change as
well and if they change other people who
are in their safe secure bubble right
now might reject them or might not like
them or might think that they've got too
big for their boots or something like
that I think that people are more scared
of success than they actually realize
and then that leads to self-sabotage and
that leads to not doing the things that
you know would work because there's
something in there have you had that
like where you've sort of your I guess
success and Entrepreneurship and stuff
has meant you've lost touch with the
people that you used to hang out with I
think that when I sold my agency I
realized that the existential crisis
that I was facing was not
relatable at all yeah what do you mean
so it's like I sold the agency that I
started I was 22 at 32 and all of a
sudden I didn't have an identity in a
work sense and so people would ask me
what I did and I'd be like don't know
what to say and sometimes I'd be like oh
well I I sold an agency and then I
figured that was in the past but how far
in the past can it be before it starts
to not be relevant at all and so I think
there was some element of feeling like I
needed to find what it was to Define
that work side of me
but because it was like it was a really
good exit because I had a like I had a
good time and because I had all this all
this space it was like there's not
really it's not really a difficult
problem so it's very hard to get people
to actually feel sorry for you because
you don't want people to feel sorry for
you you just want to somehow figure it
out so I think I probably spoke to fewer
people than I would normally about
challenges because it was so unrelatable
so you started the company at 22 you
sold it at 32 are you allowed to say how
much sold it for um I normally don't go
into the exact details but I can tell
you that it was a it was a seven fig
exit and I was really happy with how it
went and also it was off the back of a
really interesting time because there
was a week in March
2020 when my company shrank by 25% in
one week and that was because we had all
these clients in Hospitality travel
events they were all having a horrible
horrible time because of coid and the
horrible time that they were having then
passed on to us so it was a week of just
the phone ring non-stop my email going
off non-stop with just clients canceling
and I just remember thinking what is
going on what are we going to do and um
I think that probably the most important
question just in life is how can I use
this and I'm so happy that I had this
Lucid moment of using that question at
that exact time and figuring out a plan
so so what I I did was got all the team
together rallied them all up and figured
out how we would use this and I think I
was very inspired by other people in my
network who had pivoted so fast so there
was a friend um there was a friend
called Rob and he was going all over the
world teaching people how to present and
how to pitch and in about three days
after lockdown after the first lockdown
he changed his entire company he renamed
it presenting virtually and he started
teaching people how to present virtually
on zoom and set up their Zoom Zone and
he was he was doing videos on LinkedIn
every single day and just getting new
clients and I was like oh my God people
are people are pivoting so fast we need
to do something and I just didn't want
our company to get any smaller and I
didn't want to have to lay people off I
was like really scared and
so rallying the team and thinking about
how can we use this led to us using all
our spare capacity of which we had
absolutely loads to create courses and
to talk to our clients and to almost
develop the middle of our funnel so
before then we'd done a lot of
networking meeting people and we'd done
a lot of Google ads lead generation but
we almost didn't have this like actually
nurturing people and keeping in touch
with people so we started really
doubling down on that went from hardly
emailing our database at all it was like
once a year to once a day and running
webinars every single day talking to
them creating courses they chatted to
other people about us and we managed to
grow the the company back to normal
another 20% this is in 5 months and we
still had all our clients who had gone
to come back so it was at that point
where it' be the craziest summer ever
where I thought I feel like I'm not the
leader for this company anymore I feel
like it's ready to go to new hands and
someone else is ready to take it on and
um probably the main reason for that is
because I've been running it as very
much a lifestyle company so I'd been
leaving someone else to run it leaving
people to it as much as possible trying
to create as much Freedom as possible
within my role as a agency owner and I
was faced with this reality
of either having to get so back involved
and grow it to the next level or risk
being tapped on the shoulder again when
another pandemic hit and I had to do the
same kind of thing and I didn't want to
do that so that was the moment I was
ready to sell and because we were on
that growth trajectory that's when
selling my sense and that's why it was a
good
exit how did it feel when all the money
landed in your account and you just look
at your account and you're like whoa I'm
rich um it felt pretty cool I think the
main thing was not even that the the
money side of things the main thing was
the actual Freedom that real I cannot be
tapped on the shoulder because even
though I had a really amazing team a
really awesome general manager who
looked after everything and she saw it
as her personal responsibility to make
sure that I didn't get bothered with
anything we actually called it deploying
jod when you needed me I would be
deployed and if not other people would
take care of it and it's like if
anyone's thinking about hiring a general
manager that is who you need someone who
sees it is their personal responsibility
to take to to protect your time and put
you out of a job so the main thing was
the freedom um and that made such a
difference and that was very cool and
that was cool but also strange but
overall positive nice so
starting a social media marketing agency
is like one of those things that has
become the equivalent of due paage
surveys or start affiliate marketing
it's like a very like these days if you
watch a YouTube video about how to make
money on the internet a lot of people
will say oh my God just start an smma a
social social media marketing
agency as someone who has built and sold
a smma over a 10-year period to what
extent would you recommend someone start
a social media marketing agency if
they're looking to start a business so
great question it's a really good
business to start because it's super
simple to start because you you barely
need any startup cost you need knowledge
and you need enthusiasm you need
confidence and you need to work out a
way of getting in front of clients and
them saying yes when I started in 2011
it was such a niche area like it sounds
crazy that social media was Niche but it
really was so I almost didn't need to
Niche down so we didn't work with a
specific type of client we worked with
all clients we didn't work on a specific
platform we worked on all platforms if I
was starting it now I would I would
Niche down so much I would be like
LinkedIn for dentists or Twitter for
carpet cleaners or like something where
it was so Niche that it's like that is
my person that's who's going to help me
so I think it's still a viable business
I think people still need the help I
would just really double down on this
one area this one platform and just be
known as the experts in that okay and to
what extent is running an agency okay so
I've basically never met an agency owner
who actually enjoys running an agency
business
um I feel like in your case you became
the owner rather than the operator so
you probably had a more chill time of it
but my my understanding of agencies is
that you have to scale headcount as you
scale clients and therefore there comes
a point where you're like H if we want
to grow anymore we have to hire more
people and then it becomes a total
nightmare is that fair to say or how how
was your experience of it yeah that's
very fair to say and mainly they do work
like that and if they don't work like
that it's because you're not necessarily
scaling headcount you're scaling the ad
spend and then you're taking a higher
percentage of that but that has problems
as well because as the ad spend goes up
you're taking a bigger percentage and at
some point the client goes Hang on we're
paying like 50k a month we don't need to
pay 50k a month so you lose you almost
become a victim of your own success and
then that has problems at the other end
of the chain as well but with my agency
it was definitely that every time we
added 30 hours a week of client work
we'd add a new team member and then we
kept growing like that and if you don't
like hiring people if you don't like
managing people definitely start an
agency now I've started a software
business I've got the whole agency
versus software thing which is quite
interesting in in how they're how
different they are but it can be it can
be really fun it can be a really good
way of making money you get to work with
a lot of interesting people and it's so
simple to start some of the best stories
I've heard of agency to software
especially is where someone starts an
agency they aim to get to a certain
monthly amount in revenue and then they
use that to develop products or to
develop software products especially and
then they keep going with the software
products they know how to Market it
because they've got an agency and then
the goal is to replace their agency's
income with the income from the
product okay so what so you run a
software company now what are the key
differences between agency and software
so in agency you can make something up
and you can sell it straight away and
then you can start delivering it in
software you probably shouldn't do that
because you if you make something up and
then you sell it at some point you have
to build it and that takes longer so
it's very front-end loaded in software
it's like you build the product and then
you sell it and then people buy it from
there um one of the main differences
that I found which I think is a good
thing but it could not be a good thing
at some point if I take it too far is
that in our agency our clients are worth
thousands in our software business our
clients are worth $99 a month and so
it's very it's a a very different type
of relationship but I'm still
conditioned to think of everyone as
being an agency client so now if a
software client cancels I'm like no what
have we done come back we can work this
out like you know we can we can change
things and they're like okay needy and
so there's just no need to be like that
but um I think what we're trying to do
is apply the agency care to software
clients without it going too far and
without losing sleep over it what does a
software company do we create art ially
intelligent coaches and mentors based on
thought leaders so it's called coach Fox
AI we have creators who sign up they
configure an AI model to coach and
Mentor in their style so they' we've got
these little style sliders where they
choose whether they're more coaching
style or they're more mentoring style
whether they are funny or serious
whether they are um informal or formal
and then they upload their content and
then that AI model is like them and so
they use as a lead generation tool so
people in their audience sign up chat to
it ask it questions get help and get
guidance based on their content and
their Frameworks oh that's very cool so
could I do something like that yeah you
would be I mean you would be absolutely
perfect and it would it would be so
perfect for productivity as well because
you're not there but your content is
working on your behalf yeah Ali Abdul AI
yeah we also have because we've got we
always get questions for our YouTuber
Academy students where it's always it's
always the same sort of stuff and I've
got like 80 hours of me talking about
how to grow on YouTube and answering a
load of questions I was kind of think
like people are asking all these
questions and if they had just watched
episode number 67 the 67th hour they
would have known the answer to that but
obviously they don't they haven't got
time time to do that so could I just
like upload everything I've ever said
about how to grow on YouTube and turn
that into a how to grow on YouTube like
chatbot kind of thing yeah so we are on
a massive Vendetta against Dusty content
so you know it's on episode 600 whatever
said but no one else necessarily does
but it's like you've already done the
work you've already put all the hard
effort in once you train an AI model on
your content and your Frameworks and
your personality it's like it's not just
doing the work for you that someone
might not have found if even if they
weren't digging through archives but it
makes your content about them so it's
like what's your problem how can I help
you not necessarily oh read this and
figure out your own way of applying it
to your life so it's very um yeah it's
very focused on your audience and a lot
of our creators are using it as a lead
generation tool on their website but the
ones who aren't are either charging for
Access so people are paying like $10 a
month to access an AI coach version of a
Creator or they're putting it in a
membership site so like as a value ad to
save them answering all these questions
every single week that they've already
asked before and do do customers get
annoyed if if they know that it's an AI
model that's replying they know it's an
AI model it's it's very clear actually
we did have an inquiry to say it was
from a teacher actually who said so I
know it says AI at the top but can you
remove the AI and I know that your chat
boot respond straight away but can you
make it respond like at random intervals
and she actually wanted to pretend that
it was real so that she could just I
don't know how do you feel about that um
we are so we're not in that business but
um I mean I'm sure I'm sure it'll happen
one day but arza very much this is an AI
version of this person and that's quite
important when you're training it as
well because if someone says Hey Ali ABD
AI what are you wearing you want it to
say well I'm not actually him I'm an AI
model based on him like stop asking me
weird questions let's get back to
productivity now or something like that
because it's not actually you and so
having that separation is quite
important you mentioned you were running
the agency as a lifestyle company yes
what do you mean by that so I think
there are four games that you can play
in business oh love it
what are they I think one of the games
is the artist game and that's where you
are you're the talent you've got this
art you've got this craft you've got
something you do that's different to how
anyone else does it and it's magical and
the goal of this game is for you to do
as much of your art as possible and
everyone you hire their goal is to take
away the friction and do all the admins
so that all you need all you can do is
Rock up and do what you do and they take
care of everything else so that's the
artist game you could do that ever yeah
pretty good game yeah the other game is
the lifestyle game so this is the one
that I was definitely playing for most
of my agency's life and this is where
your goal is to make a certain monthly
amount say but try and do that as
possibly as possible so you work as
little as possible and that money comes
in and you spend your time doing
whatever you want so for me it was
traveling and it was competing in
powerlifting um and doing kind of other
stuff other than running the business
because the goal of the business is to
fund your
lifestyle and then I think there's the
performance game and that's what I'm
definitely playing now and this is about
seeing what you're capable of so in this
game you are probably prepared to forgo
elements of your
lifestyle because it doesn't matter
quite as much so whether you get to the
beach one day a week or five days a week
doesn't matter as much as growing your
business to be really impressive or make
the most impact possible or make the
most money possible or whatever your
goal is and then I think those three
games can all be infinite games you
could play all of those forever CU you
could always tend towards being a
worldclass artist or you could keep
going with the lifestyle game and just
make your lifestyle amazing or you could
just see what you could reach in terms
of performance and become a billionaire
but then the fourth game is the build it
and sell it game not an infinite game
has a probably like a threeyear lifespan
or however long you're going to do it
but that is your goal you're going to
get in and you're going to get out and
that is the game that's cool let's
explore okay I'd love to dive more into
into these cuz I think I'm playing some
combination of the artist game and the
lifestyle game
and I am currently in a bit of a dilemma
where about a year ago Dan Priestley our
mutual friend came over and he was like
you know told us the difference between
lifestyle and performance and I was like
cool lifestyle all the way but now I'm
starting to feel like I also want impact
and if I could wave a magic wand and 10x
our revenue and and our impact and our
profits I wouldn't say no to that so
it's like
I'm not I'm not sure if I want to play
the lifestyle game or but I'm not I
definitely want to keep doing the artist
thing because if I free up my time I'm
not going to travel and do powerlifting
I'm just going to make more videos cuz I
just love the artist side of things but
I also want a Chill Lifestyle but I also
want impact and so like I kind of want
to have all three slices of this cake
how how would you go about like I'm yeah
this is a struggle I'm having right now
I think the way of a magic one question
is the exact right question to ask
because that will help you decide which
one comes first I feel feel like you're
not playing the lifestyle game I think
you are but I think if someone said to
you you can get all your dream guests
that we've just talked about on your
podcast and it would mean that you
couldn't go on holiday for a year you'd
be like yeah I do that yeah I don't
really care about going on holiday yeah
or whatever like whatever comes as part
of your dream lifestyle I feel like you
you would forgo that but I feel that's
because you've got the artist identity
at the same time you know you're on
something you're on an upward
trajectory you're seeing what you're
capable of at the same time I don't
think you're playing the lifestyle game
I think I might be playing the artist
game then because as you were saying
that like the goal is for me the goal is
to get everyone in the team to deal with
everything other than reading learning
and making videos yeah which is the
thing that I love doing yeah and I would
just do more and more of that if I had
if I if I had 100 million in the bank I
would still read learn and make videos
and do podcasts CU it's just fun okay so
just for you we're going to invent this
fifth category oh nice and it's called
the artist performance game okay and
that's just both that's where you're
maybe you're an artist of like next
level where you can treat it as a
performance game at the same
time because you know you know what
you're good at you've subtracted the
stuff you're not good at you know what
you can double down on like if I said to
you okay how do you T your business you
could probably tell me because you've
thought about it as a performance
business at the same time so you've
almost you are the artist but you're not
like you're not like the starving artist
you're the artist who can zoom out see
themselves and then go how do I turn
this artist into a performance business
H that's interesting this is the first
time I've thought about it in that
way H cuz I guess I thought I wanted a
lifestyle business because but what I
actually wanted was to free up my time
to focus on the art yeah of making
videos and writing books and stuff MH I
don't want the lifestyle business so
that I can work four hours at we can
chill on a beach and travel around and
stuff yeah and if I do do traveling
around and stuff I'm like great let me
chill in a library all day in like a
different country so I can do more
reading and make more stuff I mean
there's an argument to say that that's
because you know how you're motivated
and you've also found your purpose
because I think part of the reason I
wanted to do the lifestyle business was
because I wasn't I liked my business but
I wasn't so like right now I'm like oh
my God this is going to take over the
world and I don't know if the business I
was running then I almost was out
growing it as I was building it and
therefore the lifestyle things sounded
more exciting cuz we go with ever is
going to give us the most sense of
progress or the most open mean and maybe
it wasn't the business itself it was
more the lifestyle sides that's what I
tended towards interesting so if you'd
won the lottery you wouldn't continue
running a social media marketing agency
you'd be like great sorted yeah I think
so whereas now if you won the lottery
you my life would change yeah you'd
continue doing the software stuff I
think that's a really good question if
you won the lottery would your life
change and if it's a yes then it's like
you're probably not living your dream
life right now
h if you were in the lottery would your
life change I wouldn't make any courses
okay and I I wouldn't do any
sponsorships yes okay uh and I would
reduce the frequency of uploads mhm
because currently our frequency of
uploads is like based on growth and
metrics and like sponsors and
stuff but my calendar would not change
very much I would still do the same
stuff MH um so this is interesting as
well because another side
of being a I call it like a high
performer or being world class in like
one or two areas yeah I think a really
big part of it is
subtraction and so there's a bias I know
you love biases I think we've geeked out
on these before but um there's one
called addition bias and it's where
whenever you're faced with like a
problem or a challenge the the bias or
the tendency is just to add stuff so I
once knew a guy who had seven Vas and so
every time a VA got full he just added
another one and he kept going until he
had seven and he didn't ever stop to
think like why the hell do I need seven
vas because in the like he really didn't
um and then you've got like I don't know
if you're if you're sad you might feel
like okay I'm going to go shopping or if
you want to if you've got a problem in
your business you might think okay we
need to hire someone or we need to add a
report or we need to add something else
and it's just always add add add but the
the actual thing to do is probably to
subtract
and it's probably to subtract the things
that are the six and sevens out of 10
like courses like sponsorship like the
stuff that doesn't really light you up
because then you get all this free time
and this free space to think how do I
get more tens but we never we're not
going to get to the tens without
removing the sixes or the
sevens
H so what I would do is perform this
giant audit of your whole life I really
like doing this exercise I do this every
time I'm feeling a little bit out of
kilter yeah and it's a it's a blank
piece of paper and there's a vertical
line and there's a horizontal line and
it just says start stop more less okay
and you completely ignore start and more
so a St box a stop box a more box and a
less box Y and you're going to make it
come up on the on the screen beautifully
yes we animate this so start and more
are what addition bias is telling you to
do it's telling you to put stuff in
there it's like it's saying no you need
to add stuff like you need to hire
people you need to add reports you need
to add products but we're going to like
cross them out you can violently cross
those boxes out that's good that feel
good and then you focus on stop and you
focus on less and you think what am I
doing how am I filling my week in things
that just don't matter there might be
habits that you're just doing without
questioning they might be things that
suit a previous version of you but don't
suit current version of you or they
might just be things that you know deep
down you either don't really enjoy or
don't move the
needle and then you remove
them I think the hardest thing is
identifying them and then after that
it's like removing them and um I think
it can be a really tough challenge
because when everything's working just a
little bit so say if I said to you how
do you grow your YouTube channel and you
said well 10% of people come from here
10% come from here you're going to list
me all these different places and you're
going to say so I should stay active on
all these different platforms I should
keep doing all of these things because
you know if I stop then we'll lose those
people but that's not the case if you
stopped you would free up time you would
free up space and you would be able to
repurpose that into fewer things in the
theme of less but better and those
things would compound and they would get
bigger and they would get
better and then weirdly they'd probably
grow the other things I've been doubling
down on I've got a column in Forbes on I
write about entrepreneurship and AI I
write a lot about chat GPT prompts and
in the five years I've had the column
I've had five million views five million
paid views but one million of those have
been in the last
month and it's because I stopped doing
everything else I stopped like I don't
log into Twitter anymore I don't log
into Instagram anymore I just write for
Forbes and do that all the time because
it sends people to coach Fox Ai and that
doubling down and that like fully leing
out on this one thing that you do has
meant that that one's exploded and it
then passes on to the other things as
well like my linkedin's grown more than
like ever before now I don't even focus
on it because the other things grown so
much so it's like subtracting doubling
down less but better I think it's the
way okay uh this this thing around so
social media platforms is
is vibing
but we are trying to be on all the
social media platforms um because of you
know trying to be a thought leader and
staff it's good to be on all the
platforms um primarily my focus is on
the YouTube channel and on the podcast
and we do and when we film shorts for
the YouTube channel which is good
because it grows YouTube We also copy
and paste them onto Instagram and on Tik
Tok um when we film videos for the
YouTube channel someone in the team
repurposes them into tweet threads and
Linkedin posts and stuff and so like
those things are happening through the
team but they're not taking up my own
time and my own head space m is that
okay or is that still would you still
say that that's a bit dangerous I think
it's fine I think when I said to you if
you won the lottery what would change
you said courses and sponsorship so I
don't think social media is the beef
yeah I think there are other things that
are your six sevens of course in
sponsorships bring in the revenue yes
which is the problem yeah but then they
bring in the revenue right now like this
is almost why people stick in jobs and
don't start their own businesses
you're right okay go on continue they're
bringing the revenue right now so we get
used to this level of comfort yeah that
we can't break away
from and so we just we keep going with
it we just settle so many of us are
operating so far under our potential
that it's just like embarrassing and so
this is why it's like cool on
your life look at your schedule look at
what you're doing look at your look at
what you're trying to achieve and just
be like how do I stop doing all these
average mediocre normal things so I can
free up my time and just be well class
at a few things H that's
good this was a thought process that led
to us canceling our YouTuber Academy
because it was like a life cohort course
nice okay after like two and a half
years of being like kind of like too
much money to to let go of I I had this
realization of like no screw that M we
can still generate revenue from it by it
being a passive Evergreen product it's
going to be less Revenue than it as a
life cohort but it means it frees up
like three months of my life a year and
that was a price worth paying mhm um and
how did you feel after you did it pretty
good it was scary initially because I
was like well I don't know if we're
going to manage to make the revenue that
we need to this year MH but we were like
I was like yeah we'll figure it out I'm
sure we can yeah yeah yeah there's a
phrase I really love and it's um jump
and the net will
appear and it does all the time every
time
you I've mentioned in the past a
personal success system what is what is
a personal success system
I think everyone on the planet has a
personal success system they just might
not know exactly what it is and some
friends who popped in mind are is the
friend called Shona who has a business
called perfect English grammar and her
personal success system is going to
events because what she finds is that
every single time she goes to an event
she'll meet someone she'll get an idea
she'll she'll something will happen and
in the 6 months after her business
doubles and that's happened like three
times now so because she knows what it
is what her personal success system is
she can apply this going forward and she
can just go to bigger and better events
and she can she can kind of take the
cruxs of this system and just keep
applying it and everyone's second
favorite billionaire Jeff Bezos has a
very similar thing where he he will
think of an idea he will write a onepage
press release about it he will see how
that goes down with a very small group
of people and then he'll just build it
and then he knows that a few of them are
going to take off some of them aren't
Amazon's got like 157 businesses that
it's started that didn't go anywhere
like you remember the dash buttons and
the um and the fire phone and like
random stuff and it's like yeah we'll
give it a go might work might not that's
like his success system is coming up
with the idea writing the press release
releasing it and seeing what happens and
I realized that I had one too where if I
look back at anything that I'm like
proud of or anything I've achieved I
pretty much followed the exact same
system to achieve it and so this is
going to be different for everyone but
mine is set the intention speak to
someone who's done it ask them how they
did it find out a method and then split
that method into something that I do
every single day for about half an hour
and just keep going until it happens
that's just that's just my success
system and so when I worked this out I
was like I need to test this with other
things so the next thing I had in mind
was to write a book and get a publisher
so I followed the exact same process and
it just worked and there's almost
something in like when you figure out
what your unique resources are what your
unfair Advantage is what your like
somehow weirdly placed to do with your
resources or the things around you you
can figure it out and then apply it
going forward and I think you can kind
of achieve anything so I don't know if
you know what yours
is
like the top three like the top one
thing that you've ever achieved that
you're just super proud of it probably
had a method from the start to the
finish of how you got
there H as you were saying that I was
thinking about the very first cohort of
our YouTuber Academy which was like the
first product we released and just
completely exploded the business
overnight basically and that was I had
the idea while I was sitting in a
Starbucks in Cambridge journaling in a
physical pen and paper I was like this
would be a good idea banged it out over
the next several weeks Non-Stop and then
three weeks later the course was live
and made 30 350k and that was more money
than I'd ever seen before in my life
have you replicated that since with
other things I remember the first
business I started that was successful
again zero to MVP in about 3 weeks I had
the idea while I was at the mosque of
like let me build a company that sells
medical admissions courses and boom we
were up and accepting payments within 3
weeks because I was just like I was like
cool I'm just going to do the thing not
overthinking it not worrying too much
about what people will think and just
having that sort of iterative kind of
mentality so the initial idea comes from
you not being in front of your
laptop yes that's very true the initial
idea comes from you having the space
being somewhere different having a pen
and paper Y and then after that what
made with each of those ideas did you
have the conviction that they would work
straight away I had the conviction that
they might work mhm and so it was like a
lot of this could work let's just give
it a go how many of the ideas that you
write down in your Journal do you think
oh that won't work I'm not going to do
that one quite a lot so there's
something about those ones that made you
think this is worth doing yes so I'd I'd
find almost the metrics around that
because that's probably a system as well
you've probably got like all the ones
that I've written down that I've found
out or that I've thought would work had
these characteristics that they probably
all got in common and then the next
thing you did
was banged it out over the next few
weeks with the team I'm guessing that
probably followed the exact same process
as well solo initially and then the
second one was with the team of just
like all right Scrappy let's just bang
stuff together let's not overthink it
let's just whack it up you know and in
both cases and actually I think in in
all
cases I got my hands quite dirty with it
it wasn't like uh I'll just sketch out
the vision and let the team execute it
was like I'm in making the landing pages
myself and doing the copyrighting myself
okay and like in the nuts and bolts of
it so getting Scrappy boots on the
ground taking imperfect action and then
launching yeah and then current current
Network current audience yeah just put
and I mean the first time around I
didn't have an audience so I had to post
on the student room and hope for the
best second time around I had Twitter
yes and so Twitter was where I was and
sort of building it in public as well
second time around so this is your
system this is exactly your system
coffee shop idea set of criteria that it
matches taking Scrappy action and then
just doing it you could apply this to
anything going forward your next thing
that you want to achieve yeah this is
the thing so it's like I I'm I'm also
thinking you know when I was writing the
book most of the progress was made in
like very short bursts of time there was
this week where we were at a team
retreat in Wales and some nice Airbnb
and I was like cool my job for this
whole week is just write one chapter a
day and from morning to evening I was
just like I'm just going to write the
chapter and I wrote like 50,000 words
that week yeah and I've never like
that's by far the most productive I've
ever been in my life in terms of like
word count whereas it took like 2 years
to write 10,000 because I was just like
overthinking and outline all this sort
of stuff I wonder if some kind of magic
source that works for you is this taking
away the pressure of it being good and
being okay with it being like this is a
disgusting first draft but like it
doesn't matter because it's going to be
like it's going to be fine cuz you
there's probably something in there that
means you trust where it's going to go
so you will accept a level of
imperfection because you know it's kind
of part of the story but you know I
quite like to think about like the movie
of your life like if this was a movie of
your life right now then you there in
your cabin in Wales writing the book
like that would be there and it would be
a really fun scene and it would be like
there's like rain outside and there's
like sheep barring in the distance and
it's like it's this glorious kind of
thing and you're there like and like
scrunching it up and going like that and
like it would be cool it would be cool
so there's may be something that's like
you know it's part of the story you know
it's ultimately going to lead to success
that lets you get out your own way and
just put words on the paper which is
powerful because loads of people can't
do that because of the writer block
thing yeah I think recently we've not
followed the system because we now have
a head of product who's responsible like
you know been wanting to make a
productivity course for a while if ID
followed the system I would have just
like banged it out in 3 weeks and it
would be done yeah but now we're like
well we've got to have a product and we
should like we've got a big audience now
it's kind of a big deal we should do
this properly and therefore we should do
the competitor analysis and we should
figure out what the offer is and we
should follow the methods and yeah all
this kind of stuff and I can see the
value in that but I'm also kind of like
feeling feeling the sense of like I just
want to make it in a weekend yeah cuz I
think I can make it in a weekend rather
than a six-month period of like back and
forth with with a head of product I
think it's a really valid point and I
think it's almost why startups will
always do well because they don't have
this sense of oh we need to do it
properly whereas like businesses that
have been going a very long time they've
got like policy and HR and procedures
and stuff they have to do so they
they almost become irrelevant because
they are following so many different
procedures when the startups are like
we're just going to do we're just going
to execute and we're going to get on
with it so maybe getting back to the the
scrappier the scrappier you might be the
way so I guess just thinking about this
out loud I could do the scrappy version
0.1 soft launch it to like Twitter in
the email list see what
happens and then at that point I lose
interest in it and then I can head it
over to a team team member to take it
from 0.1 to like 100 yeah because you're
the Visionary yeah are you an eent TJ uh
yeah yes yeah we're the same but yeah
that's exactly it the the e means you're
super extrovert the N means the it's
like the Visionary the I've got these
great ideas but then you need someone
else to go and and the t means very very
logical the J means that you can plan it
all out but ultimately you don't even
though you know what the plan should be
you don't want to execute the plan so
that's where yeah team comes in and goes
hey there's all these cool stuff cool
things in mind and they do it
sick so how how would someone go about
finding their own personal success
system think about the things that
you've done that you're most proud of
and not the things that you think you
should be the most proud of but the
things you're really secretly the most
proud of and then figure out what you
did from start to finish to make them
happen and do that with multiple things
and then find patterns whatever they are
however weird the patterns are it might
be that everything that you've ever
achieved on a on a really cool level has
always involved this one person or has
always involved this one coffee shop in
Cambridge or whatever it might be find
those patterns and then go to those
people go to those places again and try
and replicate it that's good that's very
good oh by the way in case you have not
yet heard my book is about to come out
it's called Feelgood productivity how to
do more what matters to you and it's a
book that I've been working on for the
last 3 years now it's being published at
the end of December 2023 but pre-orders
are actually available and I know people
don't like pre-ordering the book but if
you do pre-order the book and you email
me your receipt you will get completely
free access to a live exclusive event
that I'm hosting in the first weekend of
January of 20124 and this is a live
online Workshop all about annual
planning goal setting and reflection and
so I'm going to be facilitating a group
with hopefully hundreds of people from
all around the world and we're going to
be going through how to figure out what
to do with our life and how to turn that
into goals for the year and how to build
systems and how to be consistent with
stuff and how to make sure that we are
enjoying the journey along the way that
is purely exclusively available for
people who pre-order the book as a thank
you for our little community so if you
want to check it out you can check out
the book you can maybe consider
pre-ordering it the link will be down in
the video description okay so my action
point from this so far um I love you got
homework from this yeah no I've started
doing this recently because I I realized
that I do these interviews and if I
don't have a piece of paper in front of
me to write it down I just forget what
what happened and then it'll be released
on the channel a few months from now and
I'll be listening to it as if I've
listened to it I'm like I had the
conversation like how how do I just
forget literally everything that we
talked about yeah so now I like make a
point to write action points so my
action point is to stop and
L and also to sort of make a MVP of my
personal success system PSS MVP do you
keep a personal
CRM I've always I've dabbled but I've
never managed to make it
work so something I've started doing
which I quite enjoy and it feels very
effortless is after I've hang out with
someone I'll open up the voice notes app
on my phone and I'll just when I'm on to
the next place or when I'm leaving I'll
record just like a 5 minute voice note
of like what we talked about how I feel
um the kind of stuff we covered like
what was really good to cover and um
what they helped me with all the action
points and stuff like that and then um I
saved them and then firstly it's good
for the next time you meet them listen
to it back while you're on the way there
and then you remember like oh they were
going to do that thing and then you ask
them about the thing um but then also
you you really get to understand who in
your life gives you energy because you
just know how you feel after you're
hanging out with them and then that can
help you work out the people in your
life who are the NES and the T compared
to like the six and the sevens CU you
imagine like oh my God I just left that
meeting I feel terrible and then it's
like don't hang out with that person
again they are not good for
you yeah that's a good system um i' I
I've had various situations of this
where I have like an Apple notes folder
called people and after I've hung out
with someone I'll just like open up
their note and then just add some stuff
at the top to be like talked about XYZ
they're planning to go to Leia next week
all this kind of stuff mhm and I would
do that for a few weeks and then I
always forget and it's like it would it
would drop off as a habit yeah um and
I've tried finding various I I think if
someone made that what what you just
described plus AI yes to be able to
automatically update a personal CRM
using a voice note to be like here are
the the highlights from your
conversation this that be cool this is a
call to the internet please can someone
out there make an app call it better
friend and have it where you can just
upload the voice note and it does stuff
and the next time you meet them it puts
it in your calendar ask them about this
like tell them about that follow up this
tell them that you put into practice
that tip that they gave you and just
just do it mate this is better friend. a
better friend friend I'm going to
message A friend of mine straight after
this to be like to make it yeah CU he so
he's um recently quit a job in
management consulting and is trying to
build AI software and so he built a
Premier Pro plugin that helps cut out
pauses and stuff using like G chat gbt
whisper and all that crap cool um and
he's looking for ideas for products to
build and this would be a very cool one
yeah be really good cuz I think
friendships progress when you don't have
to tell the same stories twice because
people remember them so you know if like
you've got someone who you maybe see
twice a year you want the conversation
and the relationship to progress each
time but it's not going to happen if you
don't remember things because they'll
just tell you the same stuff and you
won't remember so you'll be like oh
brand new information when it's not
brand new information so the Gap that
you fill is forgetting those little
nuances that help progress relationships
that's good I really suck at keeping in
touch with people because I mean I guess
you're on inag like I don't know if this
is just a thing but like I have like
five five zillion unread whatsapps and
like friends will message and I'll not
see the message or it's it'll just be
buried in the Inbox and then looking at
just scrolling through my WhatsApp and
being like Oh God it's all this stuff
starts to feel very overwhelming and
then I feel bad because I'm like well
like I'm not I'm just not replying to my
friends do do you get this at all have
you tried inbox zero for WhatsApp no so
you can go on WhatsApp and you can
configure it so that all your chats are
archived and only new messages come into
your WhatsApp inbox and then it means
that you treat your WhatsApp like a
to-do list almost so you could batch it
so you could have like a respond to
WhatsApp messages every other day for
however long and then once you've
responded someone and the balls in their
Court you swipe you click archive and
then it disappears yeah and then you've
only got like however many at the top
nice but sometimes it becomes you if you
gamify it yeah I'm sure I can find a way
to yeah I can definitely find a way to
gamify this I'm just looking at it now
it becomes a game that can take over but
at least you know that everything that's
in there is in your court and if you've
said something last and it's up to them
you're not going to see it nice okay
that's good it's this is all about
creating blank space like everything is
just remove stuff from like your inbox
your schedule your life so that you can
just double down on fewer
things yeah that's very cool um what was
the story behind the 10year career
book 10year career book was all
about when my agency's exit was going
through I was very impatient and I was
impatient because there was due
diligence there were lawyers there were
things that had to be sorted out and
there was just no point me hurrying the
process up because nothing was going to
move anything faster so it was like an
acceptance of having to be patient and
just having to do nothing and so I wrote
a book that's when I wrote a book okay
so for the first I I followed my
personal success system I got up went
straight to my laptop each morning and
for the first 90 minutes of each day
wrote a book before my agency completed
and the idea behind all of it is this
ethos of do cool stuff and then help
other people do the same cool stuff and
I think that kind of serves two purposes
one is that you never really feel like a
impostor and the reason you don't is
because you're only ever teaching people
stuff that you have already done
yourself so you never feel like oh I
don't know anything about this because
you you've done it and secondly I think
it really hammers home the importance of
only asking advice from people who have
done the stuff because everyone wants
you to give you advice all the time but
most of it completely irrelevant but if
you always ask people who've done the
stuff then you'll get real guidance that
matters and so the point of the book was
to take all the lessons from 10 years of
running a business between the ages of
22 and 32 and I guess it's running it
it's setting it up being the artist
trying to run it as a performance
business realizing I wanted to run it as
a lifestyle business and then selling it
um is to take all the lessons and pass
it on to someone else so that they can
do it too so they have the potential to
start a business run it sell it it and
then maybe never have to work again
everything is sales what do you mean
everything is sales that's one of that's
chapter six everything is sales because
if you don't make sales then you don't
have clients and if you don't have
clients you're not self-employed you're
unemployed and also making lots of sales
has the tendency to make other problems
go away because now you've got sales so
if you've in an agency you're going to
have problems with your team you're
going to have problems with your your
office your systems your everything
everything everything
but as long as you've got enough clients
you can just figure out everything else
but the moment you have to find clients
as well as deal with all the other
problems then you've got lots of
problems yeah I've definitely seen this
with our team with with with loads of
other business owners I know as well
where actually just having loads of
money coming in solves a lot of like in
a way it hides a lot of problems yes and
it also somewhat solves a lot of
problems some some people would say it's
a bad thing because you don't realize
that there are problems because the
money keeps on coming in y but others
would would say well you'd rather the
money come in than not so yeah I think
that having sales can mask problems that
could then escalate because you're not
paying them attention because you're
like what do you mean there's no
problems we're making sales but if you
can make sales and grow your company and
also be creating systems and processes
and so much of that book is about
systems and processes and the kind of
what I went through to mean that it
wasn't me that ran it if you can do
those at the same time can create
something that is scalable and salable
and isn't a headache to run at the same
time nice chapter one is called The Lies
We Live be about questioning limiting
beliefs how do you how would you advise
someone go about that yeah this is about
questioning limiting beliefs it's also
about that education and career conveyor
belt that we discussed at the start but
then um talked about in the first
chapter is something that absolutely
fascinates me and it's menu
psychology and this is when you go to a
restaurant the menu that you see in
front of of you is very deliberate
there's stuff on there that is like
psychologically Pro like primed to to
make you spend more and I learned this
when um I used to work in a Italian
restaurant and they we had a a
soundtrack that we put on in the
evenings and it was called music to
watch customers buy and buy was
buy and the idea of this soundtrack was
that it rewired the customer brains to a
channel that made them want to spend
more so it was all about like being
lavish and treating your lady and like
looking nice and being like kind of
showy and it was like you it was so
strange like I'd find after work I'd be
like hey let's hang around for a drink
like let's enjoy the place it's a really
nice like it was it was making me do it
as well even though I just work there
and so I looked into this a bit more
when I was researching the book and I
found that on a menu in a restaurant
normally the most expensive item goes is
in the top right because that's where
your eyes go first the purpose of that
item is to make everything else look
cheap so it's like that's where the
mixed grill goes and that's where like
the lobster thermador goes or whatever
and if some idiot buys it that's fine
it's like your um if some idiot goes for
your keynote price then that's fine um
but the idea is so it makes it that it
makes everything else look cheap and
there should never be any currency
symbols because once you see a currency
symbol you think of money and you're
like oh no and you tighten up so we
don't want currency symbols we want
things ideally no decimal places but one
maybe never two never a pound sign never
a dollar sign you don't want the numbers
lining up because if they line up you
can compare so someone can just pick the
cheapest cheapest whatever um the the
wines people won't go for the top
because they they won't go for the
cheapest one because they don't want to
look cheap they'll go for the second one
so that one's got the biggest profit
margins and there's all these little
things and really it's not just about
menu psychology it's about the
psychology of everything around us like
we're being conditioned to believe that
we need to get a job settle down
whatever all those normal lifestyle
choices we don't realize that we're kind
of being led along the path that might
not be right for
us something different might be right
for you I one one thought on this so I
was at a a Tony Robbins event a couple
of weeks ago business Mastery um it was
about how to T through business and
stuff did you walk through fire uh no
that was that's Unleash the Power with
it which is a different a different one
this was more um vanilla than that uh
but one of the things that was
interesting was there was a lot of a lot
of stuff around you know close your eyes
and imagine the financial abundance you
can have in your life and with your
business and imagine how great it would
be if you could 10x your business and
imagine how how would it feel if you
could if you could you know fly your
family private and you know this sort of
stuff and before
that I'd never once vaguely entertained
the notion of ever flying private cuz
like
I mean I'm I just freaking love that I
can fly business class most most times
but now I'm like huh maybe I do want to
100x my business so I can startop flying
private and conveniently kind of the
upsells and stuff to the stuff that he
was selling came sort of Fairly straight
fairly soon after that whole like
imagine this financial abundance that
you could have and when I got back home
I was thinking a lot
around kind of aspirations to grow the
business in
that before I was like I'm pretty happy
you know we're doing a few million
profit a year it's fine like life is
good but then afterwards I was like but
it would be cool to 10x that that would
be really cool
and I was I I wonder for you having gone
from lifestyle to Performance business
to what extent do you think your desire
to grow the performance business is a
case of buying into the more is better
narrative cuz we are also fed the
capitalist Narrative of like well a
bigger business means you're more legit
and you're a better business owner and
like you're worth more and all this
stuff yeah is that something that you
that you struggle with at all yes
definitely so firstly on visualization
at your event visualization super
powerful and thinking about stuff before
it happens I love the idea of that and I
did it with my agency sale I wrote
myself a pretend check and it was for
the exact amount we sold for and it had
the date that was like two weeks away
from when I actually met the buyer and I
signed it like the perfect buyer and all
that kind of stuff and I stared at it
and I like watched it and I wanted it to
come true and I do it with every single
training session like I visualize my
deadlifts before I deadlift and then
they just happen and they feel easier
because it almost feels like it almost
feels like you've already done it in
reality even though you haven't and then
you're stepping into the version of
yourself that you've already imagined in
your head it's like it's weird however
it works um but on the
whole fulfilling a kind of version of
you that has these goals that other
people are telling you I think that
comes so much down to mtic desire and
copying what other people want without
necessarily questioning it and I think
you were actually the person who first
told me about mtic desire and it was
when we spoke the very first time and I
am sure I left that call being like ah I
want a YouTube channel why don't I have
a YouTube channel because it's like you
were so like happy with your channel
like everything's everything was going
really well you were telling me about it
and it's so easy to be like oh maybe I
want that too and that was literally
like an hour's conversation so it's like
that's happening all the time and I
think I think for me the whole lifestyle
business and performance business I'm
part of a membership group that's all
lifestyle businesses and so that's quite
interesting because I'm I spend a lot of
time with people who are in that game
and so when you're having conversations
and when you're kind of in different
masterminds and talking to each other
about your businesses you really do get
the chance to question yourself and to
say is this what I want or do I believe
it's what I want because all these
people around me who are very very happy
selling me the version of their life
that they think I should have too so I
think it matters who you hang out with
because you could easily for for metic
desire even from an hour's conversation
there's something like um you pick up
someone's accent within 10 minutes of
speaking to them I found myself doing
that quite a lot yeah because we're
because we it's a um I think it's a
evolutionary thing because we don't want
to get excluded from groups so we just
try and be like other people so we don't
get rejected from them that's deep
deep but it's the yeah but it's the same
because first of all it's like what do I
really want knowing yourself I think
there's a chapter in that book called
know yourself and then choosing who you
hang out with so you make sure that if
you know you do want to start a YouTube
channel you're hanging out with
successful YouTubers but it is really
what you want to
do have you come across that book
wanting by Luke Burgess no it's it's
really good it's it's about mematic
desire and it's like a whole book about
sort of exploring like Renee girard's
philosophy on mematic desire and stuff
mhm um I just writing down that I just
remembered that I'd WR I've read this
book like twice and I should do a video
about it because it's really good yeah
um but that book always really really
makes me think whenever I come across a
highlight from it he talks about like
thick desires and thin desires and thick
desires tend to be the ones that have
sort of built up over a very long period
of time and you feel like they're true
to you and all that kind of stuff thin
desires are like my desire to grow my
business which is like depending on
whether I've been to the US recently and
hung out with eight figure entrepreneurs
will immediately change the way that I
think maybe I want growth yeah and then
what the team has started saying is that
whenever Alie comes back from a trip
we're just going to ignore everything he
says for at least three days because
chances are he's going to reconsider and
be like actually I don't mind being
chill I don't I you know I like the fact
that you know our business is at this
size and it's manageable but then PM is
like I'm not sure how much I'm holding
myself back because I'm just like I
don't know scared of hard work or some
like that you
know it's just deep introspection it's
figuring out out how you are motivated
and then following that and just not
being not being sent off track by other
people who probably put forward a very
compelling case because they are happy
so if you so if you imagine if you're
kind of if you're here just going along
thinking of your goals and then you go
to an event and then you kind of go like
this for a bit and then you turn back to
normal where your normal is is probably
still a bit higher you've probably still
had some impact from it but the
challenge as a fellow entj is not
getting so carried away that you try and
overhaul everything it's trying to get
the nuggets and get those little things
that people have said that do make the
difference without just completely
changing who you are because probably
the consistency of who you are and your
message is what's got you here so far
it's like doing it without losing that
yeah that's a good that's a good point
like figuring out what's the Nugget that
I can take away from here because I
think
the the Temptation is let's just
overhaul the business but that's usually
not a good idea yeah so something I
quite like thinking about as well is the
single line or the single phrase that
describes how you are
motivated okay what do you mean so um I
hadn't really thought about this before
until a friend who has a he's got an
Amazon affiliate site and his big goal
was to get to number one in terms of
monthly hits and he told me this was his
big goal he told me that he was doing
hermit mode for like a year to get there
until he was number one and he showed me
this thing that he' made on Photoshop
that was like a leaderboard of his
website which was currently I think I
think it was like number four um and all
these like competitors like Rivals
enemies I think he called them and he'd
set it up like a video game and it was
it was a video game it was a leaderboard
and all the ones below him he' struck
through and he'd written killed so it
was like a very V violent it was a very
violent leaderboard and his goal was to
get to number one and what he knew is
that leaderboards motivated him the idea
of killing the competition motivates him
the idea of like being right at the top
having put the work in is like his real
thing and I tried to do it with my
business I tried to do it with Coach Fox
AI I said to him so how do I replicate
this and he kind of showed me what kind
of leaderboard I can make he had a look
on Google see who had monthly traffic
similar to ours etc etc and I looked at
this leaderboard and it did nothing for
me
I was not motivated at all to do that
because that's just not my success
that's not my main motivating factor so
it's like finding yours and in a similar
way to um how we came up with your
success system go back through your
biggest achievements and figure out why
it meant so much and why it really meant
so much so
like setting up a bit setting up your
own business might not be because of the
financial stuff it might because the
freedom stuff stuff um like having kids
or um getting married or like any
anything that you ever think like yes
this meant a lot it might not be because
of the reason that other people think it
should mean a lot there might be
something in it for
you and mine I know because a friend of
a friend who I had a chat with sent me a
personality test I think it was the
insights personality test and it's so
long you answer all these questions and
I I think I had like 24 pages whoa um
but one of the lines in it was is
motivated by the idea of succeeding
Against All
Odds and when I look back at
stuff the main thing that makes the
difference and stands out in anything is
when someone says to me like there's
hardly any chance of you doing that or
oh this is like only one in a million
people do this or I remember at my
company's thirdd birthday party and our
lawyer came and said oh W done you've
got you've gotten the 10% of businesses
who own who make it past three years and
I was like yeah of course we have but I
quite like I like this idea that there
are really really really Slim odds and
that we're going to we're going to smash
them that's interesting cuz that nothing
for me as you were saying that I was
like it's so interesting and I speak to
so many people who are like oh you know
someone told me I couldn't do it and
then I thought it I'm going to do
it and I'm like really that's motivating
um I was on a podcast called built to
sell and John Moro the host said
something like we've done 300 episodes
and of all these 300 episodes you're the
only one who sold without having to do
an earnout and in my head it was like
300- one and I was like that's me that's
the one and that's like the thing that's
the real thing whereas the leaderboard
yeah nothing but the there's other
things so it's like find yours and then
use that again going forward and kind of
fabricate situations that will mean that
you are motivated because you can think
of it in that way just like my friend
Richard with his leader board and
killing all the competition sick adding
an action point I want to reflect on
this and figure out what is my single
phrase when it comes to motivating
because and going back to your point
about meeting seven and eight figure
entrepreneurs and then believing that
that's what you want to do too yeah they
if you talk to them about what really
motivates you one of them might be I
want an eight fig business because
something that happened in my childhood
meant I see that eight figure business
as success I'm motivated to do that and
then it's pointless you going after
their goal because it's not your goal
because you're motivated by something
else but you need to find yours out
first
H nice it's good stuff
um one of the things you um you wrote
about is using your default mode Network
so I've written about this in my book a
little bit but I'm curious like how do
you think what's what is a default mode
Network and how should one use it so
your default mode network is how your
mind figures out
information when you're not actively
thinking about it and it can only really
be used when your brain waves are in
Theta not
beta and one of the stories I love is
Thomas Edison do you know the story
Thomas Edison used to take naps to
access his theer brain waves and he used
to go for a nap and he would hold like a
ball that was like made of metal and so
he'd be he'd like kind of think oh okay
I want to solve this problem and then
he'd like try and nap and try and doze
off and then the moment he did do off
the ball would drop and it would wake
him up and then he'd start writing down
the Amazing Ideas he had and you know
when you have like you go in the shower
and then all of a sudden you get this
idea or you go for a walk and um the art
the writer Julia Cameron who wrote The
Artist way she used to say that she went
for this walk every day and she went up
the hill and at the top of the hill
that's where that day's inspiration
would just find her and then she'd know
what she was going to write for the rest
of the day and I love the idea that you
can use your default mode Network to
actively not think about something and
let it sit in there let it we away and
then all of a sudden the answers then
find
you that's good and I do it very
deliberately between work and Sport so
one of the rules is after I've done five
great hours of deep work that day and I
go train when training from the moment I
start warming up to the moment I finish
I don't I don't go on my phone at all
it's in airplane mode and I don't use it
and it's because I want my default mode
Network to be so focused on powerlifting
that it's wearing away on all the work
things and that when I go back to my
laptop after answers just arrive and
somehow it always does but I think
because we are never really bored and
because we're never really not doing
stuff we are always in those beta brain
waves and therefore we're just always
like
always on it always going from thing to
thing and looking at notifications and
actively thinking and then we don't get
chance to use probably the most powerful
part of our
brains nice how do you use yours legit I
started doing a thing where I would um
back when I was filming I was I was
trying to film like one video a day I
was like I'm the first thing I'm going
to do is going to film a video and then
I'll then I've got the rest of the day
free and so I would figure out what is
the topic what's the what's the title
and then I'd go for a walk around hide
Park and and during the walk I would
sort of be half thinking about the video
and half not and sometimes mind would
would W and usually by the time I was
back I was like cool I've got it and
then I'd sketch it out on like a A3 pad
or something and I'd F I'd film the
video that felt like quite a fun way of
making stuff um I was also sort of
indulging the inner kind of Julia
Cameron artist kind of Vibes and there
was a good interview I did with a a guy
called shien yesterday um he's got a
Twitter account called the cultural
tutor and he's grown from zero to 1.5
million followers on Twitter in like a
year he was working at McDonald's and he
decided you know I'm going to quit my
job at McDonald's and start writing on
Twitter I'm just writing a thread a day
for the last 500 Days and his thing is
that he wakes up at like 5:00 p.m. he
has has a pack of cigarettes he irons
his shirt and tie and trousers and then
he just goes for a walk and he'll walk
for however many hours it takes for
inspiration to strike and then he'll run
back home on his laptop right the thread
nice and then he go sleep um and I mean
is now one of the most writers on
Twitter so yeah so good and it probably
feels effortless as well yeah cuz your
mind's just doing all the stuff while
you're doing other things and then all
of a sudden it's like here it is like
Julia CRA especially she'll talk about
she doesn't write like she doesn't
actively write she talks about like a
muse coming through the pen and she
describes it in this really like
beautiful way but it's because she's
given her mind the chance to just think
um I've I've been I've been feeling very
over over scheduled recently yeah yeah
how do you how do you think about that
um yeah also in Mad Men the um Don
Draper used to just sometimes say to his
PA cancel everything clear my schedule
and I think remember that you've always
got the power to do that because you can
so keep that there as like a freeing
thing remember that everything's a
choice because it should be a choice I
think before you book stuff in your
schedule it's probably quite good to
think how would I feel if this was
tomorrow because when you book stuff
that was three months ago it's so easy
to say yes and you might have people in
your life who are very good at getting
you to agree to things three months in
the future and you'll say yes because it
seems so far away and then all of a
sudden that's tomorrow and then you're
like H I have to do that thing um one
tactic I've heard someone use is to not
schedule anything on Mondays and Fridays
because then it means that it squishes
their week down and it means that if
they ever want to go away for the
weekend it's very easy to do so that's
nice I quite like the maker manager
schedule where you think about the
morning as being when you're a maker you
do all your deep work you don't book any
calls whatsoever I do that like I I will
like guard my morning time so fiercely
like if I got a delivery I wouldn't open
it until after I'd been to the gym it's
like it's very it's like sacred time um
and then it means in the afternoon you
can do your manager work which is like
the admin the schedules the calls the
everything else so especially if you're
a performance SL artist then it's like
when are you the
artist H you mentioned 5 hours of deep
work and then gym H where did the 5
hours come from and how do what does
that look like just made it
up um it looks like getting up in the
morning and doing some element of like a
walk or cardio or something and that'll
be before looking at phone checking
email doing anything at all and then the
most intense work I can possibly do that
I've probably thought about the day
before and then I know what I'm I'm
doing and stuff that is in My Success
system so it's like a arrive at the
laptop do it do it do it hammer it out
know that you're working on something
that you really believe in so it doesn't
feel like work I think like getting into
flow in getting into flow on stuff that
you really believe in is just magical
and then when that's done GO train for
powerlifting and don't look at my phone
at all and then when I get back to my
laptop then there's there's answers
that's when they just arrive that's that
Julia cam and like they just find
me that's a good system yeah I think it
works and I do it every day I call it my
perfect repeatable day like I I try not
to think in terms of weekends and
weekday because it's kind of a
social structure that we don't really
need and is probably not that applicable
to lots of people in the world and I
think once you stop thinking in terms of
weekends and week days it gives you a
better sense of freedom and also I I
think it lets you plan life on your
terms quite a bit more because you
realize that you don't have to do
everything when everyone else is doing
it so you can get what I kind of call
this is in the book as well there's a
whole section on lifestyle design but um
you can access like the first class
experience by just switching your
timings so don't go to things that are
really popular on the weekend when it's
popular go at like 5:00 p.m. on a
weekday or go to the go to the gym like
I train at 2 p.m. because like no one's
in there and it's perfect but you could
do that with everything in your schedule
so that you get the first class
experience and then just work when
everyone else is doing other stuff how
does so you do a lot of things at a very
high level um uh how how how does like
spontaneity and chilling out fit into
your perfect repeatable day so um it all
fits
into a structure that is a vend diagram
okay and so it's like profession
Obsession decompression and I think
about about everything I do in terms of
those three things and so to Define each
one profession is like your work how you
make money not I don't mean side
projects I mean like how you make money
the main thing that you're focused on
the stuff that only you can do so like
you as the artist or you as the business
owner not you as the the admin assistant
that you shouldn't really be doing
yourself that kind of thing so that's
profession and then obsession is the
main thing that you do outside your
profession that you're trying to get as
good as possible at so for me it's
powerlifting because I I compete in
powerlifting and because I'm I put a lot
of energy into making sure I'm really
really good at it but for someone else
that might be another serious hobby it
might be like gaming if they do it you
know like it can't just be something
that you're like oh yeah I'll go to the
tennis court and hit a few balls around
it's got to be more like I'm doing this
with a mission I'm doing this because
I'm going to get really good at it and
then your decompression for me is like
traveling and hanging out with friends
and it's where you just completely
switch
off and so normally in a diagram you've
got areas of crossover but the beauty of
this framework is that the main reason
it works is that there is no
multitasking to be done at all so the
idea is that multitasking is like the
enemy because multitasking is like
responding to emails in between bench
press or like thinking about my later
session while I'm writing an article or
like doing something that's meant to be
completely relaxing but not being able
to switch off from work stuff so the
idea is that everything that you do in
your whole entire life fits into these
three areas there's no there's no like
gray areas at all and then it means that
your default mode Network can work on
your profession while you're doing your
obsession and vice versa and then you're
applying the same success system to both
as well so all of a sudden it sounds
like this magic like it kind of sounds
like a magic thing but I really think
that is exactly how you become world
class in more than one area it's very
intentional M so it's it's a vend
diagram but it doesn't have any
crossover it has a crossover but they're
like colored in so it's like don't go in
these areas don't go in that zone they
are no go zones okay cuz that is where
so if you're trying to do Prof if you're
trying to do your work in like a chilled
out fashion you'd be like you're sort of
halfing both both things yes like on a
Saturday when I'm like oh I should be
doing some work spend the whole day
doing all because I haven't
intentionally committed to either
working or decompressing yeah just do
one or the other because I think it can
probably happen quite a lot as well with
like high-powered individuals who are
always like go go go you don't see the
decompressing as being a thing you see
it as like something that you feel
guilty doing but making it
intentional means that it's like no it's
okay I'm not working now I'm not
training now I'm intentionally like
exploring this city or sitting in this
coffee shop doing nothing or chilling
out on the sofa and it's like I'm doing
this so that I can be better in the gym
or so I can be better as like a parent
or so I can be better at my
work or I'm doing it so because that's
part of a life well- lived yeah exactly
yeah oh yeah I'm that
too um so for you it sounds like
powerlifting is an obsession rather than
a hobby yes I'm not sure I have any
obsessions outside of work in that sense
I talked about this framework in a talk
for the network with the lifestyle
entrepreneurs and um someone came back
to me afterwards and she said have you
got a list of approved obsessions that
we can follow cuz it was exactly the
same it was like she wasn't totally sure
but there will be something that you do
outside work that you probably could be
really really good at if you just
applied the same intensity as you did to
work and if you just applied that like
logical analytical brain came up with a
plan you could probably get really
really good at like a sport or a or a
hobby or even just being a good
boyfriend even just being a good tourist
even just there's some there's something
that you could turn into a system where
you focus on performance in
it I love the idea of getting really
good at Art it would just be so cool I I
took art lessons at one point during
during lockdown but at the same time I
was also trying to take guitar lessons
piano lessons and singing lessons while
alongside growing the business uhh and I
thought when I left my job as a doctor
I'd have way more free time and then
just I ended up working on the business
like way longer than I'd ever worked as
a doctor and just everything just got so
squeezed can you think I I dabble yeah
okay do you think no not at all really
really badly but I like that you could
and maybe that's your
obsession it has to be something that
actually lights you up though it has to
be something where you're like I would
really like to geek out on
this because it's about
applying the way that you can think
about performance to something else
other than work yeah and is that
important I think it's important because
I think it's what means that you get in
your default mode Network it means that
it works because you've got two things I
think it helps create boundaries as well
because when I didn't have an
obsession work would just expand and
work would just happen all day and I
think now I get more done because I know
it's going to get to 1:30 and I need to
leave to go train and I'm not going to
compromise on that yeah parents say this
as well they're like oh yeah like I I've
become more productive since having kids
because I know that I have to pick them
up from school school at half three
therefore I don't screw around during
the daytime like get my done yeah
I've talked this to lots of parents
about this framework and what they seem
to like is the idea that it's not just
okay here's my work and it has to stop
but it's also I'm being a parent now
like I it lets go of that guilt that
they feel like they do need to be
checking stuff on their phones or like
just respond to this email or doing
something it's like no this is my
obsession here are my kids kids I'm
going to do this and I'm not going to be
like a iPhone
parent yeah there's a book I want to
write at some point around productive
relationships M uh sort of like applying
the principles of productivity and
systemizing to relationships and
friendships and romantic relationships
and stuff I think that think that would
be a fun thing to do how do you have a
productive how do you do that um I don't
know yet um but I enjoy reading books
about it and you know I did an interview
with John and Julie gotman who are like
these world famous um relationship
therapists yeah researchers and they're
all about like systems and rituals and
having a regular date night where you
having a monthly review of your
relationship where you ask specific
questions and stuff so me and my
girlfriend for the last two years have
been doing regular relationship reviews
we have like a little notion page with
templates and stuff and it sort of spans
back for the last two years and we can
we take notes on like what we learned
from our relationship reviews nice and I
think there stuff cool cool stuff like
that where I I like it because it
applies the principles of like
productivity and systems and my very
logical brain to this area of Life
relationships which are which is
ridiculously important but which if left
to my own devices I would it would it
would be very secondary to work MH um
and I kind of want to start doing this
with health and fitness as well yeah um
like understanding what are the most
effective productive enjoyable ways of
working out in the gym for
example um so maybe that's like the
obsession side of things yeah finding a
way to apply like the performance
principles to these other different
spheres one of the um Dr John gotman
studies he's Dr love right he's known as
Dr Love he oh he might be yeah his his
lab is the love lab Sobe yeah so he did
a really cool study that I think about
loads and it's about the biggest
indicator of relationship longevity do
you know what it is I'm familiar with
the four horsemen like contempt and
criticism and stuff oh yeah okay so it
probably it's probably all part of the
same the same research but he got a
bunch of different couples into the
gotman lab like the love lab and he
hooked them all up to different like
things on their body to tell all their
different like vitals and he got them to
just talk normally and answer questions
about their lives together and then he
sent them away um and he assessed how
they'd kind of performed and the
different metrics that had come out and
he labeled these couples Masters or
disasters okay and I don't remember
exactly how long like the study was I
think it was quite a while I feel like
it was like 10 years and I don't know
how many couples he did it with but I
feel like it was at least 30 but he was
like 99% accurate on who had stayed
together and who had not stayed together
and the biggest indicator of
relationship longevity was resting heart
rate when you're around each other and
it's all to do with fight or flight and
it's like if you're around someone who
is putting you on edge who's getting you
like to go into that like oh and because
you feel like you're going to be
attacked or you feel like something's
going to happen or you feel like you're
hiding something or something ultimately
there's too much cortisol running around
your body and it just can't work out in
the long term and I think about this so
much with my team members and I did at
my agency as well because hotheaded
Founders or like entrepreneurs are just
crazy erratic Visionary I've gone to
this event someone's told me something
that's going to change everything and
it's like we're like this but not all
our team members are but if we put them
into fight or flight all the time then
we're just causing the same thing that
ultimately causes relationship to break
down so it's like how do I how do I take
all the really good things of being a
hot-headed founder and having that
impulsiveness ambitious ambitious
ambition and then and not make it impact
my team in a really bad way so I quite
like how it could be applied to work
relationships as well nice that's cool
yeah we found that since um you know one
of my team members Angus is our general
manager and sort of promoted him to CEO
recently um which I mean he was
basically doing that anyway but I've had
a bunch of feedback from Team from the
team being like the business feels so
much more calm now that Angus is leading
meetings and I'm like I'm so glad that
is exactly what we want this is good
there's um have you read principles Ray
Delio I flicked through it it's just too
long yeah is it worth reading yeah it's
really worth reading so it's in three
parts the first part is all about him
and his I guess it's almost like his
credibility to write the book so it's
like why should I listen to these
principles and the second half is life
principles sorry the second third is
life principles and then the third third
is work
principles but why it's so interesting
is because he's all about playing to
everyone's strengths and he's all about
how everyone's wired in a different way
and inspired by his book we created for
my team what we've called user manuals
okay yeah the idea that my name's Jody
I'm an entj this means this this is how
I communicate this is what really
matters to me so like um one of my like
highest values uses integrity and if
someone says to me like oh yeah I'll do
that and then they don't I find it
really hard to trust them again even
though they might have really flippantly
said like yeah yeah I'll do it and they
don't think like oh she's holding me to
this but in my head it's like but you
said you'd do it why haven't you done it
yeah and I know it's a weakness of mine
but it's like it's there in the user
manual to say don't tell me you're going
to do something unless you are actually
going to do it and it's just so helpful
other people knowing that and then I
read everyone everyone else's with such
just like interest because I want to
know how other people think so that I
can best play to their strengths but
that's been super useful in our team
understanding that someone does want the
erratic and someone is like I hate
conflict I hate confrontation I hate
everything else because it does help you
to realize how different everyone is
that's a good idea um we we we recently
had a good conversation with uh RIT
sei's general manager and she was also
like have a user manual for everyone
yeah in particular for REM because it's
like then people know what like what his
like weirdnesses and quirks are and I
was like this is a good idea yeah cuz we
are all weird and quirky yeah but it's
okay um if you think of the team members
that you have now the team members that
you've worked with in the past and you
imagine like the absolute star
performers like the ones that you would
love to clone if you could wave a magic
one and clone them what are the
characteristics of like the ultimate
cloneable team member you just given me
a really good idea to clone with Coach
walk AI the general manager at my agency
I almost want to clone her so that you
could ask so that I could ask her stuff
and she could help me sort stuff out but
I wouldn't have to bug her for that so
yeah I might try that but I think the
clonable characteristics I think
are
ownership and closing Loops the ability
to not just put something out there as
an idea but then to follow it through
all the way or the ability to not just
say oh yeah we should do that but the
but like actually actually doing it and
then saying I've done this this is what
I need from you this Loop is now closed
I like the tidiness of
that and then in the people who I've
hired because I probably I must have
done over like I've probably interviewed
like 300 people or something like that
quite a lot and a lot of the time I
think the ones who Stand Out stand out
because they're playing the long game
even in that interview even what they
talk to you about your company they're
not asking you about what their salary
is going to be in the next month they're
asking you about their plans for like
your your company's plans for the next
five years or something like that and
they're kind of bigger picture because I
feel like that bigger picture will be
applied to your company in such a better
way nice um as a boss what are some
questions that if a team member asked
you this question you would think whoa
that was a great question oh I would
love it if if I came to someone with an
idea that I thought was really really
really really good and they said so
where does this fit in our
priorities so rather than just going
with it they're like hang on hold back
there's a CEO who I know who um he's
quite an interesting character because
he says that he should never have to
write anything
down because as a CEO it should be
someone else taking the meeting notes it
should be someone else taking the
actions and anything that he needs to do
they're going to follow him up later and
they're going to tell him so he just
doesn't he makes a point of not ever
writing anything down um but one of the
ways that he is managed by his team
because he's like a crazy Visionary
founder is that someone will say to him
huh Dave that's a really really good
idea but if we do this idea it's going
to mean we can't do this idea what do
you want us to do and then he's like oh
yeah yeah and it works all the time so
someone's ability to manage a crazy
visionary would be very good ni imagine
like someone someone finds your email
because they contact you on your website
and you probably get a bunch of random
Cod emails and stuff what's what's the
sort of cod email that you would get
that that would make you think oh my God
this is
incredible I quite like it when people
ask me questions that they have tried to
Google they've tried to Google in my
answers so I've I've had very specific
ones before where someone said I've I
read your Tweet about this and I'm
wondering how I apply that to this very
specific situation or hey you've said
about your process for this but how do I
apply that to this and they just want
more applied to them and they probably
tell me how they've tried to go about
thinking about it but they want it like
verified I think getting a second
opinion on a conclusion that they have
come to is nice I like that I get quite
a few of those and then um a lot of
times I get emails from people who want
to be featured in Forbes but I really
like the ones who come to me with a very
definite we should write this title and
I think it would do well because of this
search volume and there's there Havey
people who've done that they've like
given me charts of things on Google and
how they're going up and um who they are
as a credible source for contributing to
an article on that um they're brilliant
just very researched because anyone can
just start an email and ask some random
questions but when they're so thought
out then they definitely do stand out
yeah so it sounds like something that in
the Forbes case something that makes it
very easy for you to say yes to that
yeah yeah H what about if someone's
listening to this they really Vibe with
you and they're like I really want to
work for jod like what's the sort of
cold email that would make you think I
need to interview this person oh
interesting work for me so on Coach fox.
we do actually have a like a careers
thing for people to just stay on our
radar for roles that we will probably
hire in the future
um what we used to do at my agent
was we got people to jump through a lot
of Hoops to join our team and have you
read influence I'm guessing you read
influence yeah you just go here it's all
to do with how the harder it is to get
into like a club or a team or something
the more you value being in it so um
it's like with fraternities and
sororities and how they have those crazy
initiations and like getting into the
Navy Seals it's like they go through
that really famous hell week and it's
like the harder it is to get into
somewhere the more you'll be like ah I
earn this I value it I'm going to make
the most of it so um one thing that we
used to do is we used to just say to
people like impress us and then they
would put together all sorts of
incredible things like someone made a
video like PowerPoint thing um someone
kind of was a graphic designer and they
they made little characters of all our
team and then they got them talking and
they copied our brand it was a bit like
oh my god did you do we already do you
already work for us um so something that
really makes someone stand out with how
much effort they put in in I think like
the thing that you did for um our mutual
friend Derek civas when you turned his
blog post into a cool YouTube video that
kind of thing because it's like whoa
this is
cool nice that's good um yeah I'm I'm
always curious like I I want to ask more
people these sorts of questions because
I think you know if I if I look at the
emails I get most of them are absolute
trash and it's so tragic because I know
that these people watch my videos and I
know that they listen to the podcast and
it's just like dear please give me some
ideas on passive income and I'm like oh
for sake come on and then
occasionally there is an email that's
just such a breath of fresh air that
it's like wow I have to reply to this
and invite you to grab breakfast with me
like tomorrow morning because it's just
so incredible and you've just blown me
away by the amount of effort that's gone
into this yeah and I wish more people
would understand what it takes to send
an email like that yep which often seems
to be just going above and beyond in
terms of effort I really like your point
around being impressive because you can
you know one thing you know there's a
friend of mine who was recently applying
to a bunch of jobs and he was doing the
thing of just like sending a CV out to
like 5,000 different places and I was
like dude come on like find the two or
three companies that you really want to
work at and just like make a video I
guarantee no one else will make a video
it's not that hard you can take my skill
check class on editing make a video and
I guarantee they're going to send it
around in their slack channels and then
you'll get in front of the right people
because no one else is going to do that
and he was like no that would be weird
like I'm going to apply through the
traditional channels it's like you know
they've got an application job page on
the website I was like okay fair enough
you want to queue up with the 5,000
other people then that's fine so I mean
a lot of it comes down to less but
better taking the shotgun approach
compared to the scatter gun the sniper
approach I guess compar the sniper
approach yeah taking the sniper approach
and not the scaton approach but maybe it
also comes down to being scared of
success if someone writes you a really
really good email then you're going to
invite them to go to breakfast with you
and then they have to meet you and then
they're like how they going to handle
that and then everyone's going to be
like oh my God now you got this famous
friend people that they know are going
to like feel like they've gone out of
touch with them maybe they're scared of
success maybe they're sending you really
bad emails because they actually don't
really want a response because then they
can say oh I emailed him he didn't
respond poor me yeah
maybe ask them send that back are you
scared of success is that why you sent
such such a poorly word cuz I can I've
been thinking really hard about why you
sent me such a email and this is the
only
explanation I think it's maybe also a
slight lack of empathy CU empathy
matters a lot
because if you really put your mind to
what do you like if I picture you in
front of your inbox it's like you can
the email almost writes itself because
you can think about what kind of thing
is going to make you go huh yeah that
resonates there have been a few emails
that I've gotten where it's been like
hey oie um you're probably reading this
on the toilet right now in which case uh
Happy pooing or something just like
you're absolutely right like I now have
to read the rest of the email CU they
would they know you too well where are
you where are the cameras yeah exactly
are there any um changing it slightly
are are there any sort of systems or
Frameworks that you apply to your
relationship that have been helpful
every Saturday morning my husband and I
go for coffee and pastries oh cute yeah
it's really good the pastries we go to a
different place and it's like a yeah
it's a nice ritual and that is where we
debrief the week and we've got it's very
structured but it's kind of fun
structured so we have a um a Google form
and it's got like a kind of updates and
progress on these different things and
it's like his sport my sport our
business um different stuff and also
travel plans because we both we live at
our suitcase we um have been kind of
nomading for about two years now and we
we normally know where we are about 10
weeks ahead but no further Okay so um so
sometimes we think we're going to be
somewhere for a certain month and then
it's like oh no we don't really fany
that place anymore so we'll kind of
update that um but it's really nice
because it's such
a it's such a way to reflect on the week
think about improvements but also just
hear from each other because we spend a
lot of time doing the stuff but not
necessarily taking that step back and
then being like well did I enjoy doing
the stuff or do I want to do more of
this or how can I help help you become
better at CrossFit how can you help me
become better at powerlifting and
everything else so yeah that's a big
that's a big part of it and I think
going back to the Dr love John gotman
thing really making sure that we don't
put each other on edge and part of that
is like I think not bringing someone
else your drama and being very clear to
not bring someone else your drama it's
like a thing because I think um with if
you look at films TV shows about like
husband and wife couples often husbands
are just portrayed as these like useless
characters and I feel like I'm that
might have impacted me at some point or
I might have started to almost have this
impression of what a husband is you know
like someone who oh is a bit rubbish and
they um they don't shut drawers and they
don't plan stuff and they forget your
birthday and all that stuff and if you
believe what the films tell you then you
could you could slip into that and you
could just think oh mine's useless but
then you're like well actually mine's
not useless so I don't want to treat him
like that just because the films tell me
I should so it's more self-awareness and
trying to trying to not put someone else
on edge with my drama nice Jody I think
that's a great place to down this thank
you so much um if someone has gotten to
the end of the the nearly two hours that
we've been we've been talking um where
can they find more about you and your
work so the main place to find me is on
Twitter so um I mentioned that I I think
success is all
about doing really cool stuff and then
teaching other people how to do that
same cool stuff and so I constantly
share what I've learned what I've what
I'm passing on um and at the moment it's
a lot of chat GPT prompts it's a lot of
how to build an AI business um if you
want to find me on Twitter I am jod cook
so J O D I
eore cook and tell me that you found me
on here and I will happily send you my
latest course blog whatever it might be
um at the moment actually there's a 250
chat GPT prompts for entrepreneurs about
productivity and growing a business but
depending on when you listen to this
watch this it might be something else
amazing um but yeah definitely find me
there say hey be really good to hear
from anyone who this is vibed with
brilliant and we'll put links to all of
the things in the video description and
the show notes thank you so much thank
you all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye